Sam I will start with you you have had
the opportunity to work on Nick Fury
with a number of incredible directors
over the years what is something about
ali that stands out and maybe helped you
tap into something new that you've never
accessed in him before uh interestingly
enough you know when I first started
this Ali was one of two directors
and
I met with him and then I met with the
other director and the next day the
other director had quit
[Applause]
scaring him or what you know but I think
it's great that ali uh stuck and even
greater that they allowed him to direct
all the episodes uh so it gave us a
consistency of
um
I guess a consistency of idea or a
concept that he had for what he wanted
the show to be so he was able to shape
it in that particular way or convince us
that we were shaping it in a way that
you know was our way but turned out to
be his way I asked Ali about uh the
choice to direct all the episodes and
he's like I don't know someone else made
that decision I guess I guess you made
that decision then
I'm just joking with you uh Olivia so
for for you I always love asking this
type of question for a character who
pops on screen with so much confidence
and Authority what do you think Sonia
thinks her greatest asset is at the
beginning of the season but then also
what do you think she fears is her
greatest weakness oh oh my God
yeah um greatest yeah this is
you come to make me actually concentrate
this is really difficult
um greatest asset at the beginning
uh I think she thinks that uh Noah's
gonna get the better off her I think
she's really on it uh
um she knows what's happening she knows
you're there uh
I think she kind of feels like she knows
everything what did you say about the
second part this is one I'm more curious
about her greatest weakness or what she
thinks her own greatest weakness could
be oh my God I mean this is in-depth
stuff that I never thought about when I
was actually filming it
um maybe she has allowed uh her feelings
to come to the surface bit which is
something she's not used to
she's
I think potentially that's she thinks
that might be a a weakness I like that
answer I like that answer it makes me
even more eager for the rest of the
season she has a level of sentimentality
for Fury that she doesn't have for other
people yeah she's crossed that she's got
that yeah well speaking of that Dynamic
and also because you two are some of my
favorite working actors in this business
I love asking this question in general
but to be able to pose it to the two of
you makes me very happy right now can
you each tell me something about the
other as a scene partner that you really
appreciated and maybe helped you crush
something that was super challenging in
a particular scene of the show I was
nervous coming in joining you know when
you're sort of the new girl
um and I got to say sam the second my
lady dies on Sam
just loud and warm and we giggled
straight away and I said it before today
but a big hand on my shoulder went we're
going to have so much fun and and he the
generosity and the kindness to to allow
someone to come in and to sense you know
I've done this I've been here I know all
these guys and I'm going to take you in
and it was beautiful and it meant that I
could do my thing and you did your thing
we trusted each other it was from that
moment many people wouldn't have been as
kind maybe or didn't need to be as kind
and it was very welcoming I love those
vibes beautiful person but my concept of
of going into a scene with with most
people all the time is that we have a
plan uh we rehearsed it once and the
plan spontaneity is there supposed to be
spontaneous we don't know what we're
going to say to each other but it's
planned spontaneity and she surprised me
with the level of sincerity and care
that she gave this guy even though she
was telling him he was flawed and it
allowed me to find some other place to
go with Nick Fury other than that you
know smart ass stuff that he always
comes up with both excellent answers to
that question I cannot wait to see more
of this Dynamic after they let us see
more than two episodes they give us two
episodes and then they're like no more
and I'm sitting there like I need the
rest of the season I can't wait to see
you congratulations